100 um 100 yes  why did you say that  um  it distorts the expectations i think  and you become addicted to things that  aren't in reality or at least are not  are not within the realms of what you  can do within your relationship  um  it's just it's dangerous man it's  dangerous it's bad it's don't do it  what do you mean you can do in your  relationship um  so  i guess it depends so if you if you if  you have a kink for  a particular thing or a particular angle  or particular whatever it is and your  partner can't do that or if you train  your brain to release or to feel  pleasure associated with a particular  visual and in your relationship you may  not be able to not necessarily recreate  but event you're used to your partner's  face or body or whatever it is  but important is different people  different angles new